garlic johansson and colin jost are
ready to tie the knot on Sunday a rep
for Johansson confirmed to ET that the
34 year old actress and Saturday Night
Live star are officially engaged after
two years of dating adding that no date
has been set for the nuptial the news
comes one day after the SNL season 44
finale where Jost anchored his final
Weekend Update segment of the season
with no mention of the big news of
course the two first sparked romance
rumors in May 2017 when they were
spotted kissing after Johansson's
appearance on the NBC show the couple
was most recently seen walking
arm-in-arm on the red carpet at the
Hollywood premiere of Avengers endgame
in April where ScarJo joked about her
plans to use Jost to play a prank on her
Avengers co-star Paul Rudd when he
hosted the Saturday Night Live season
finale I've got connections I'm gonna
make sure that his time is really
difficult you guys I'm gonna sabotage
him I'm gonna come in from the inside
like he doesn't know what's coming the
engagement will mark scar Joe's third
trip down the aisle the 34 year old
actress was previously married to actor
Ryan Reynolds and journalists Roman
Dorie ACK with whom she has a
five-year-old daughter congratulations
to the happy couple
you